this is petty history that's right we
are covering the pettiest feuds in the
entire world we're historians of the
pettiest degree you ready let's do it
let's go
number one joan crawford and betty davis
two hollywood stars one big ass view
these two competed for roles were pitted
against each other and also both fell in
love with this dude franchot tone he's
cute i guess no he's mine he's mine keep
your eyes off of him and let's get the
wedding bells cued up because it sucks
to suck
joan married the dude but he was mad you
got it after being rivals for decades
the two of them teamed up in a horror
movie called whatever happened to baby
jane have you seen that
exploitation exploitation yes high
exploitation definition it's where
hollywood takes two quote-unquote
old-ass people and puts them in weird
horror movies
sexism alive and well anyway they're
shooting this movie and betty got to
drag joan down the hallway
[Music]
you're so damn heavy and in the scene
supposedly rumor alert she put rocks in
her dress pocket
and then betty supposedly
threw her back out
well that's because rumor alert you
kicked me in the head
i'll stop being such a drama queen it
was a light tap
it wasn't a light time whatever happened
to baby jane premieres betty gets
nominated for an oscar joan isn't take
that joe
why me hmm
what can i do oh i know joan talks to
two of the other best actress nominees
hey anne mancroft what's up how about if
you win an oscar i accept it for you
since you can't go i can't go yeah you
can't remember oh maybe i did say that
sure you can accept it for me and
betty's there waiting hoping she'll get
her oscar but she doesn't and bancroft
wins instead excuse me
wait a minute is that joan crawford joan
steps up to accept it for her i'd like
to thank the academy i almost dropped
dad but betty got the last laugh because
joan died first and when joan died betty
supposedly said rumor alert you should
never say bad things about the dead only
good joan crawford is dead good damn
petty baby number two the blackest black
let's go back to 2014 shall we yes we
shall a year where pharrell gave us
happy john travolta gave us adele dazeem
and kim k's butt on paper magazine ah
the good old days there's a new color
vantablack the darkest color in the
world it absorbs you guessed it 99.96
of light damn that looks like a black
hole there's this british artist anish
kapoor he's the artist behind the
chicago bean by the way my name is
cloudgate
it's a little more like this
anyway this guy kapoor buys the
exclusive rights to van to black in
2016. he is literally the only person
who can use it wait why i don't know why
do you like the spice girls hmm touche
this other artist stuart semple thinks
this is real uncool so what does he do
he creates his own color i call this the
pinkest pink
and it was available to anyone who
wasn't kapoor before you buy you must
attest you are not anish kapoor you are
in no way affiliated to anish kapoor
and you are not purchasing this item on
behalf of anish kapoor no but i wouldn't
be doing that or an associate of anish
kapoor no i'll show them kapoor said he
don't give a damn about the rules up
yours hashtag
and obtained some pink paint anyway post
you're kidding no he really said that
actually oh it's on i'm making an even
darker black a black 2.0 and a black 3.0
and you won't be able to use any of them
you would never i will fun fact black
2.0 isn't toxic like vantablack so
that's cool i guess number three mark
twain versus the post office y'all know
mark twain right come on man tom sawyer
huckleberry and you know the post office
um i might you know but i do know that
mark twain does not like the post office
specifically addresses why should i have
to write addresses sir can you please do
you know how many words i wasted 72
words and the ink and the time and i
don't get paid enough for this one day
mark twain is sending a letter to his
friend and he forgot the address maybe i
forgot
well no matter let's see
for mr cm underhill who is in the coal
business in one of those streets there
and is very respectably connected both
by marriage and general descent and is a
tall man and old but without any gray
hair
and used to be handsome buffalo new york
from mark twain p.s a little bald on the
top of his head
sealed with love wow and you really
wrote that too and guess what the post
office actually delivered it now number
four martha stewart versus gwyneth
paltrow clash of the titans i think it's
safe to say martha doesn't like goop
martha please tell us what do you think
about gwyneth paltrow and goop she's a
movie star if she were confident in her
acting she wouldn't be trying to be
martha stewart
well
that's gold she really said that too and
you know what gwyneth did gwyneth
poaches the ceo of martha stewart living
for goop so anyway remember when gwyneth
paltrow and chris martin split up they
call it a conscious uncoupling oh yeah
everybody does i have a glorious idea
for an article about pie flavors we'll
call it conscious coupling say whoa
let's start it like every thanksgiving
table should be blessed with the
presence of a long married pair who
bring out the best in each other well in
that case i also have a perfect new
recipe it's called jailbird cake how
dare you i served my time clearly not
enough i hate you
number five no dogs allowed lord byron
was this old poet guy he was a student
at trinity college way back in the
forever ago the 1800s right right right
and
like any other student he wanted a pet
but no dogs are allowed on campus no
dogs allowed
but did you read the fine print fine
print i have got a new friend the finest
in the world a tame bearer
[Music]
uh you didn't say anything about no
bears why would you bring a bear on
campus i don't know i'm bored
number six i'm ready finishing a strong
let's put a dead pope literally on trial
like is in a dead dude in the courtroom
as in picture this the year is 897 and
the brand new pope in town stephen vi
decides he's going to be extra dramatic
and put his former dead predecessor on
trial that's right pope formosus is
going to trial y'all no absolutely not
they literally exhume his body out of
the grave that's right nine months after
his death they decide to dig him up and
put him on the stand and boy did steven
put on a good argument well i guess pope
stephen number six let's hear your
argument well your honor i have to say
rah-rah-rah blah blah blah yeah
you get it oh does nobody see this as a
dead man why is there a dead man here
what's happening are we putting the dead
on trial he's literally falling over you
propped him up not well enough and pope
for moses how do you plead
shockingly for moses didn't say much
dennis
well i guess guilty
i don't know sure why not still dead are
you all insane he's literally rotting as
we speak as punishment let's um
chop off three of his fingers strip off
his nice clothes and throw him in the
river ha ha
i win steven didn't last long ooh a bad
time for popes i guess a bunch of people
revolted stephen was later then thrown
in prison where he was strangled to
death but we're gonna dig up his grave
in three months and put him on trial
right well that's it for today's petty
history we'll catch y'all next time for
the ultimate in pettiness damn right
keep it petty people
[Music]
you